good morning John as you may have heard
there's a lot of content in the world
now what I do sort of fancy myself a
understander of media and I think that's
a really like important thing because
it's how we understand the world like
those stories that we are told the
stories we believe that we share the
ideas that move around inside and
through people and onto others that's
what humanity is so care about that a
lot I care about it enough that when
there's a new way that that's happening
a lot
I almost feel an obligation to engage
with it I can't always do that but I've
been doing it with tik-tok and I will
say upfront don't download tik-tok just
to follow me
it's a addictive platform for sure it's
gathers a tremendous amount of data
about you once that data is out there it
is very difficult to imagine what it
might be used for in the future even
though the platform doesn't want to use
it for something bad we see that that
information can be compromised but I
have this theory that we now live in a
world with functionally infinite content
that doesn't mean that all of the
content that should be made is getting
made and it doesn't mean that all of the
audience's that should be served are
getting served we need to be aware that
the platform's through which we consume
content really heavily affect what kind
of content gets created there's this
whole idea in Media Studies Marshall
McLuhan's the medium is the message the
ways in which content is distributed and
discovered influences what the content
itself becomes in a way that is so
profound that the medium itself is kind
of the content like we needed to make 22
minute long pieces of content for
American television so we could have
eight minutes of ads every half hour on
this situation comedy defined itself
around that constraint and now we live
in a world where the medium instead of
being television or radio is the
platform it's the algorithm those things
so deeply control what kind of content
gets made and for whom because another
really important part of the medium
being the message is that content
doesn't get created for every one part
of the medium and legacy media is the
people making the decisions about what
content is going to be created they get
to decide
humans not very many if we don't have
that as much but we definitely have the
fact that advertisers will pay more for
some audiences than for other this idea
that I often sort of use as a touchstone
that there is infinite content and we
sort of have to prepare for that world
isn't really true there are still all of
these constraints out there and those
constraints are different for different
media and they're different for
different people creating different
things for different audiences but in
the time I've spent on tick tock I've
never felt more like we are getting
closer to that infinite content world
because the constraints on creation have
been lowered the constraints on
discovery have been lower like the story
of quarantine has been tick tock being
like cow and kwibi which is a thing rose
like billions of dollars in trying like
interface with the best most talented
creators in the world here's another one
of my anchors Florence Italy during the
height of the Renaissance when
Machiavelli and da Vinci and
Michelangelo we're all working that
sound out about the same number of
people as Missoula Montana
it is not a lack of talent that holds us
back it is a lack of access I'm not
saying that tick tock is the Renaissance
but the talent of the creativity is kind
of astounding to the point where I just
don't feel like I could ever find all of
the good stuff and that's not a new
feeling I feel that way about television
I feel that way about books this has
something of a fracturing effect on
society where we consume very different
kinds of content and we don't have as
many touchstones in common with each
other but it also means that people who
didn't have access to that career didn't
have access to any influence at all now
get some access to that and so when we
have that sort of like off-the-cuff
observation that like I can't consume
all of the good content anymore I think
that that actually has some really deep
societal implications that are really
worth examining John I'll see you on
Tuesday